الله
الس
[Silence]
‏f
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا الله
اشهد ان
لا اله
الا
الله اشهد ان
محمدا رسول الله
اشهد
ان
محمد رسول
[Silence]
الله حي على الصلاه
ا حي على
الصلاه
ا حي على الفلاح
حي على
الفلاح
الله اكبر الله
الله
اكبر
لا اله
الا الله
ان الحمد لله نحمده ونستعينه ونستهديه
ونستغفره ونعوذ بالله من شرور انفسنا ومن
سيئات
اعمالنا انه من يهده الله فلا مضل له ومن
يضلل فلا هادي له واشهد ان لا اله الا
الله وحده لا شريك له واشهد ان محمدا عبده
ورسوله وصفيه من خلقه وحبيبه صلى الله
عليه وعلى اله وصحبه
اجمعين يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله حق
تقاته ولا تموتن الا وانتم
مسلمون يا ايها الناس اتقوا ربكم الذي
خلقكم من نفس واحده وخلق منها
زوجها وبث منهما رجالا كثيرا
ونساء واتقوا الله الذي
تساءلون به والارحام
ان الله كان عليكم
رقيبا يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله
وقولوا قو
سديدا يصلح لكم
اعمالكم ويغفر لكم
ذنوبكم ومن يطع الله ورسوله فقد فاز فوزا
عظيما اما بعد فان اصدق الحديث كتاب الله
وخير الهدي هدي محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
وشر الامور
محدثاتها وكل محدثه بدعه وكل بدعه ضلاله
وكل ضلاله في النار ثم اما
بعد
all
الله
of i pr him
se ask
for الله
gu no
[Silence]
محمد الله عليه وسل
الله
الله bless and mercy upon
household
الله trans
[Silence]
الله who created you from one soul and
created and from
[Silence]
الله الله
‏best
guid spe
of محمد صلى الله عليه
وسلم
allion myar
brs before i the topic i was to talk
about
صل الله عليه وسلم said whoever say
next mean h don't
talk he would have
committed there for
him be careful
[Silence]
‏other صلى الله عليه وسلم
‏cr care not toose this re coming
for so myar brothers and
sisters صلى الله عليه ولم our
as عليهل
صلى الله عليه
وسلم الله سبحانه وتالى
قران النبي اولى بالمؤمنين من انفسهم
وازواجه ام
[Silence]
الله sister great any
other one
‏ach salvation the day
jud unless he
testifies that there is no god wor of
الله محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم الله
messenger and one of three
questions that you g be asked about when
you be in your grave when you tri in
your grave the angels will come to you
‏say
my
الله محمد صلى الله عليه
وسلم الله
‏my servant has said the truth so open
for him a to paradise and there comes to
him from paradise from its bing from
from fruits and from the
good
inve رسول الله صلى الله عليه
‏and our صلى الله عليه
وسلم
beli that
finer to all the
man and to the and the
الله سبحانه
وتعالى وما ارسلناك الا
كفه للناس بشيرا ونذيرا ولكن اكثر الناس
لا يعلمون
[Silence]
‏is accepted from any to believe in any
propet after محمد ى الله عليه وسلم no
yeah but there is that
group that cl are
museng محد صل الله عليه وسم are not
muslim one of the pillars of
faith is believing in the prophets of
allah mm الله عليه ولم of props
الله وانه لا نبي
ب
الله قران ما كان محمد ابا احد من
رجالكم ولكن رسول الله وخاتم
النبين محمد
رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم and respecting him and pracing
the when talking
toi
andi grave صلى الله عليه
وسلم
humble respectful
الله سبحانه وتعالى
س لا تجعلوا دعاء الرسول بينكم كدعاء
بعضكم
بعض
الله الله سبحانه وتعالى س يا ايها الذين
امنوا لا تقدموا بين يدي الله ورسوله
الله سبحانه
وتعالى يا ايها الذين امنوا لا ترفعوا
اصواتكم فوق صوت النبي ولا تجهروا له
بالقول كجهر بعضكم لبعض
[Silence]
عمر بخطب رضي الله
عنه
ييد رسول
الله عمر
[Silence]
رسول الله ى الله عليه
وسلم رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم ر الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم الله سبحانه وتالى النبي اولى
بالمؤمنين من
[Silence]
انفسهم رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
سد لا يؤمن
احدكم حتى اكون احب اليه من والده وولده
والناس اجمعين
صلى الله عليه
وسلم
hold رضي الله
عنه عم رضي الله عنه
الله to
me my family my proper my
children but not
my that is my two sides
صلى الله عليه
وسلم رضي
عن
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
صلى الله عليه
وسلم
الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم صلى الله عليه وسلم
الله عليه
وسلم رول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم obedience رول
الله الله
messenger الله سهال
الله سبحانه
وتالى الله سبحانه
وتعالى
ان الله سبحانه وتعالى
قران واتبعوه لعلكم تهتدون
فامنوا بالله ورسوله النبي الامي الذي
يؤمن بالله
وكلماته
واتبعوه لعلكم
تهتدون الله
[Silence]
الله الله عليه
وسلم
indication of ling الله سبحانه وتالى how
claim that love الله ask love الله سحانه
وتالى and say yes love الله but when you
look at them you find
them not
ى الله عليه
وسلم الله سبحانه
وتالى الله سبحانه
وتالى الله ى الله عليه
وسلم الله سبحانه
وتالى قل ان كنتم تحبون
فاتبعوني يحببكم الله ويغفر لكم ذنوبكم
والله غفور
رحيم
محمد
الله
الله الله عليه
وسلم صلى الله عليه
وسلم more
الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم الله سبحانه
وتعالى اللهن صلى الله عليه وسلم اقول
قولي هذا واستغفر الله لي ولكم
الحمد لله رب العالمين والعاقبه للمتقين
ولا عدوان الا على الظالمين نعوذ بالله من
شرور انفسنا ومن سيئات اعمالنا من يهده
الله فلا مضل له ومن يضلل فلا هادي له
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك له
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله صلى الله عل
وه وصحبه
اجمعين الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم من اطاعني دخل الجنه ومن عصاني فقد
ابى صلى الله عليه وسلم
‏are people enter
parad صل الله عليه وسلم whoever me enter
parad and whoever dis me refuses to
enter
paradise so my brs and
sose par
الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم الله
ران
الله الله سبحانه وتعالى س قل اطيعوا الله
واطيعوا
الرسول سبحانه وى
الران وما اتاكم
الرسول فخذوه وما نهاكم عنه
فه
يعقوب عبد اللهن مسعود رضي الله عنه
حديث رسول الله صل الله عليه
وسلم الله سبحانه
وتالى women who connect the hairs of
others or those who connect the hairs of
others to their hairs those who do that
to them those
who the of their eyebrows to the end of
the and then عبد اللهن مسعود رضي الله
عنه الله
ع
اللهود سبانه
وما
الرسول وما نهاكم عنه
فانه ‏and whatever he has forbidden you
avoid some people have a
misunderstanding whenever they told this
is a had this is a sunnah from the
prophet صل عليه wasallam they say but
it's not in the quran only obligatory
what's the only what's in the quran is
obligatory that's not always the
case some of the things allah's
messenger صل الله عليه وسلم can make
them
obligatory just in the قران
سنه رسول الله ى اللهه
الف رمضرمضان زكاه
الفطر
حث حث عبد اللهن عمر
[Silence]
رول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم انما حرم
رسول الله كما حرم الله
[Silence]
‏allat
حرر
حث صلى الله عليه وسلم
رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم
الله الله سبحانه وتعالى س ان الله
وملائكته يصلون على
النبي يا ايها الذين امنوا صلوا عليه
وسلموا تسليما
الله pe
bl
the
all الله سبحانه وتالى
صلى الله عليه
وسلم من صلى علي
صلاه صلى الله بها عليه
عشر
الله
الله الله سبحانه وتالى
الله سبانه
وتالى
and الله سبحانه وتالى
الله pe
bless خطئ طريق
الجنه من ذكرت عنده ولم يصل عليه
صلى الله عليه
وسلم
البخيل
البخيل من ذكرت عنده ولم يصل عليه
‏sister
are صلى الله عليه
وسلم الله عليه وسلم
‏him say
him said عل
وسلم bl him and
him سبحانه
وتالى صلى الله عليه
وسلم little
[Silence]
صلى الله عليه وسلم مس الحصى فقد
ل صلى الله عليه
وسلم عليه
‏as
love
so from the this is just kind
ander sister
because الله سبانه
وتالى الله سبانه
وتالى الله
سبحانه اللهانه وتالى
الله سبحانه
وتالى الله سبحانه
وتعالى ربنا اتنا في الدنيا حسنه وفي
الاخره حسنه وقنا عذاب النار اللهم حبب
الينا الايمان وزينه في قلوبنا وكره الينا
الكفر والفسوق والعصيان واجعلنا من
الراشدين اللهم اجعلنا لك
ذكارين لك شكارين لك رهاب عليك مقبلين عن
سواك مدبرين اللهم انا نسالك رضاك والجنه
ونعوذ بك من سخطك والنار اللهم انا نسالك
الفردوس الاعلى في الجنه اللهم اضلنا في
ظلك يوم لا ظل الا ظلك اللهم ادخلنا الجنه
بلا حساب ولا سابقه عذاب اللهم اشف مرضى
المسلمين وارحم موتى المسلمين اللهم ارحم
موتى المسلمين اللهم انزل عليهم رحمه منك
وسلاما منا يا رب
العالمين ربنا اتنا في الدنيا حسنه وفي
الاخره حسنه وقنا عذاب النار ربنا اغفر
لنا ولاخواننا الذين سبقونا بالايمان ولا
تجعل في قلوبنا غلا للذين امنوا ربنا انك
رؤوف رحيم وصلى الله وسلم وبارك على نبينا
محمد وعلى اله وصحبه اجمعين واقم
الصلاه الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد ان
لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان محمد محمد رسول
الله حي على الصلاه حي على
الفلاح قد قامت الصلاه قد قامت
الصلاه الله اكبر الله اكبر
لا اله الا
الله استو ستقيم يرحمكم الله سو الصف ان
تسويه الصف من تمام
الصلاه لا شدردر فت تو
فت الله اكبر
سبحان بال
الشي الحمد لله رب العال
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
[Silence]
امين سبح اسم ربك الاعلى الذي خلق
فسوى والذي قدر فهدى والذي اخرج المرعى
فجعله
غثاء احوى
سنقرئك فلا
تنسى الا ما شاء
الله انه يعلم الجهر وما يخفى ونيسرك
لليسرى فذكر ان نفعت
الذكرى سيذكر من يخشى
ويتجنبها
الاشقى الذي يصلى النار
الكبرى ثم لا يموت فيها ولا يحيا قد افلح
من تزكى وذكر اسم ربه
فصلى بل تؤثرون الحياه
الدنيا
والاخره
خير
وابقى ان هذا لفي الصحف الاول
صحف
ابراهيم
وموسى الله
[Silence]
اكبر سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد اياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
والعصر ان
الانسان لفي خسر الا الذين امنوا وعملوا
الصالحات
وتواصوا
وتواصوا بالحق
بالصبر الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
الله اكبر
‏t
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
السلام علمه
وبكاته
ل ‏i
re
from
semp all the back the sister can
front parts and make a back for
me
part fore make
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته احمد
جابر لله وان اليه راجعون
شاء الله سبحانه وتالى
بسم الله والحمد لله والصلاه والسلام على
رسول الله صلى الله عليه وعلى اله وصحبه
اجمعين امين اللهم انا نسالك باسمائك
الحسنى وصفاتك العلى ونسالك بكل اسم هو لك
سميت به نفسك او انزلته في كتابك او علمته
احدا من خلقك او استاثرت به في علم الغيب
عندك ان ترحم والده الاخ احمد جابر يا رب
العالمين امين اللهم ارحم والده الاخ احمد
جابر يا رب العالمين اللهم اغفر لها
وارحمها واعف عنها اللهم اغفر لها وارحمها
واعف عنها اللهم اغفر لها وارحمها واعف
عنها اللهم اسكنها الفردوس الاعلى في
الجنه يا رب العالمين اللهم اكرم نزلها
اللهم اوسع مدخلها اللهم افسح لها في
قبرها واجعله مد بصرها يا رب العالمين
امين اللهم اجعل قدومها على القبر قدوما
على الجنه يا رب العالمين اللهم اغفر لها
واعف عنها وارحمها يا رب العالمين اللهم
اسكنها الفردوس الاعلى مع النبيين
والصديقين والشهداء والصالحين يا ارحم
الراحمين اللهم ادخل عليها رحمه منك
وسلاما منا يا رب العالمين اللهم افسح لها
في قبرها واجعله مد بصرها ونور لها فيه
اللهم اجعل قبرها روضه من رياض الجنه ولا
تجعل قبرها حفره من حفر النيران يا رب
العالمين ويا ارحم الراحمين اللهم ارحمها
واغفر لها وارحم موتانا وموتى المسلمين يا
رب العالمين اللهم اغفر لموتى المسلمين
اللهم اغفر لموتى المسلمين وارحمهم
واجعلهم في بطون الالحاد مطمئنين يا رب
العالمين اللهم اجعل قبورهم رياضا من رياض
الجنه ولا تجعل قبورهم حفرا من حفر
النيران يا رب العالمين اللهم لا تفتنا
بعدهم يا ارحم الراحمين اللهم الحقنا بهم
على خير واجمعنا بهم في الجنه مع النبيين
والصديقين والشهداء والصالحين وصلى الله
وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى اله وصحبه
اجمعين وجزاكم الله خيرا
بسم الله
الرح sister
and
cas
other
the was a frid i got aone call in the
and sister s
‏i
came f i said why said i don't know said
where are you said down the ro i said
can you make turn she said yes i said
turn come back she came back in the
office weed for 35 minut and then said
interest isamar said we can take that
and
said said ‏i think so and i was so
we knew say bri out l you know this we
sister
sar ف مد
this
اللهه لا اله اله الا الله الله واشهد
واهد
محد
عده
وسوله of worship
‏messenger
serv
اكبير اكبر تكبير
اكبر all
hold can wife
اشهد اهد ان ان لا لا اله اله الا الله
الله واشهد
واشهد مح مح عده ع
وسوله witness witness there is no there
is no de worthy worth of worship of
worship except except allah allah and be
wi that propet muhammad propet muhammad
‏pe be
upon m
[Silence]
س sp
open ما شاء الله ما شاء الله
[Silence]
السكم السلام مبارك ان شاء الله
‏l
[Silence]
عل